عيون مقشرة وآذان منتبهة ردود أفعال سريعة ،
هكذا يختار ما يقرب من ثلاثة مليارات شخص
حول العالم قضاء وقتهم ،
إنه ليس أكثر
الأوقات راحة ، وهذا أمر مؤكد أن
ماثيو بيكرينغ أدرك في وقت مبكر أن
لوحات المفاتيح هي أكثر بكثير من مجرد متعة وألعاب
هو الرئيس التنفيذي  من ألعاب power league ، وهي شركة
للرياضات الإلكترونية والألعاب مقرها في
دبي ، لذا فإن الفكرة الكبيرة مع plg هي أننا
سننتج أكبر بطولات الرياضات الإلكترونية في المنطقة
ونجد طرقًا جديدة تخريبية لإنتاج
المحتوى للوصول إلى جمهور الألعاب
لعملائنا
[الموسيقى]
الذين يعملون مع كبار  تنتج العلامات التجارية العالمية
مثل FIFA kfc و intel plg
أحداثًا ومقاطع فيديو مختلفة لإشراك
مجتمع الألعاب
يختلف محتواها من
الأحداث التنافسية إلى البرامج الحوارية التي تستعرض
أحدث الإصدارات أو البودكاست حيث
يمكن للاعبين مشاركة نصائحهم
في العام الماضي ، حيث افتتحوا استوديوًا إبداعيًا
هو الأول من نوعه  لطفاء في المنطقة ،
ندعو خمسة فتيان وفتيات إلى
العرض لمحاولة تضخيم مهنتهم في الألعاب
لمنحهم الأدوات
ومنحهم القدرة على أن يكونوا قادرين على أن
يصبحوا نوعًا ما بارعًا في البث
وإنشاء المحتوى ومساحة الألعاب ، لذا
فأنت متحمس للغاية
مع نمو صناعة الألعاب العالمية
بنسبة تسعة في المائة تقريبًا سنويًا ، حيث
يقود الشرق الأوسط الحزمة مع
نمو سنوي يبلغ 13
في الشرق الأوسط وأفريقيا لا
يزال هناك مجال كبير من حيث
جلب لاعبين جدد إلى السوق
من حيث توطين الألعاب حقًا
خصيصًا لجمهور عربي أكثر.
تركز منطقة الشرق الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا
على اتجاهات الألعاب المحلية
والتحدث بلغتهم
حرفيًا ،
وهو أمر مختلف تمامًا أو
محددًا لـ plg هو أننا عرب
أولاً ، لذا فنحن نبني بنشاط استراتيجيات
للتواصل مع جماهير الألعاب العربية ،
إنها علامة على أن الشركات تبحث
في مجتمعات ألعاب مختلفة
أصبحت الأهمية في المجتمع حقًا
أكثر من مجرد منصة ترفيهية
وعلامات تجارية وصناعات أخرى
مطورو الألعاب والناشرون ، يمكنهم
جميعًا الاستفادة من هذا الاتجاه من أجل
الاستمرار في النمو ،
ولحسن الحظ بالنسبة لمات وفريقه ، فلدينا شركة مليئة
باللاعبين الجيدين للغاية ،
حيث تعمل اللعبة بدلاً من انتهاء اللعبة
[موسيقى]